this is a production of cornell
university
um it's a pleasure and an honor to
introduce kirsten kurtz who was
presenting her master's thesis research
this morning
kirsten has a unique background which
has provided her with the perfect
combination of knowledge and skills for
her current career
kirsten had a family background in
farming and has worked in a diversity of
farming businesses including co-owning
an organic farm and hector new york
however she has always loved art and
explored this career option during her
undergraduate years
completing her va in painting and fine
arts at suny empire state college
she returned to her roots when she began
working for the cornell soil health
laboratory in 2012.
she has continued expanding her
responsibilities and now serves as the
laboratory manager
in this capacity she oversees six to 14
technician
technicians and the processing of about
5 000 soil samples
annually she has played key roles in
developing the methodologies
quality control and quarantine
procedures for the soil health analyses
kirsten simultaneously maintains the
website social media and the branding
for the laboratory
she has combined her love of painting
and soils and pioneered a unique
approach to soil painting
this approach has formed the basis for
the un global soil painting competition
and 2015 world soil day she uses soil
painting
as a medium for outreach on soil health
and as much sought after as a presenter
from both soil health and soil painting
you can see some of her work on
permanent display in bradfield hall
she started her graduate graduate work
in the fall of 2017
and we are excited that she is
presenting and defending her thesis
today
the title of her thesis is using the
comprehensive assessment
of soil health of remnant progress
prairies as a benchmark reference for
restoration of degraded agricultural
systems
uh thank you all so much for coming to
join me this morning
i am honored and thrilled to be sharing
the results of my ms
research um we're gonna have about five
minutes at the end of the talk for
questions but if any of you guys want to
ask me specific
questions and get into the nitty-gritty
i have my email here on the screen
okay so human-induced soil degradation
is a really big deal it's costing about
eight billion to the global gdp this has
been recently
estimated and it has five major causes
uh the first of which is deforestation
and the removal
of natural vegetation the next
is over grazing over
exploitation of vegetation for domestic
use
industrial and bio-industrial
activities and agricultural activities
which is what i'm going to primarily be
talking about today
and i'm talking about unsustainable
agricultural activities
so most of the agriculture in the world
is on former grasslands
grasslands used to cover 33.7 percent of
the land
surface of the planet and i included
this picture to give everyone an
idea of just the diversity of grasslands
and also the sheer number of space that
they used to take up across
the american midwest to the west coast
so as mentioned most of these have been
converted to row crops by that i mean
corn soy things along those lines
and because of that they're really
essential for food security
they're also hot spots of biodiversity
so they're some of the most biodiverse
areas
in the world and i'm talking about plant
species insect species
microbial community species extremely
um biodiverse and
big picture they're estimated to hold 10
to 30 percent
of the world's global carbon stock
this is a huge number and this really
talks to
the overarching importance of grasslands
to us all
um so the conversion of the great
american
prairie to agriculture really began
in my opinion with the advent of the
plow
this was invented in 1837 and this was
essential for breaking up the american
prairies
prairies are actually soils are very
dense
i was really surprised by this when
rebecca and i went out to sample
this is mostly because of all of the
roots
just stretching throughout the system
and then in 1862 the homestead act came
into play
which granted 160 acres to
some u.s citizens and this was really
the beginning
of the great kind of migration out to
break the american prairie
famously in the 1930s is when we kind of
came into
the dust bowl so the dust bowl
impacted 40 million hectares
and of the states that were affected
it's estimated that
75 of the top soil
is gone just with that one big event
um this is generally accepted as the
major cause of the great depression
and i had to share here just one picture
this painting that i found
um that was painted during the dust bowl
by alexander hogue
and i think that this really um captures
just sort of the
the destitute attitude that must have
been
um during that time and then i'd also
like to draw your attention to this
photograph that was taken
in 2011 and this is of a dust storm
coming across arizona so this is
something that is still happening to
this day
these big dust storms so conventional
agriculture um the erosion rate has been
estimated by rattan law
at 1.53 millimeters a year
and by conventional agriculture i mean
agriculture that isn't
using soil health building principles
like crop rotation
cover crops things along those lines and
then when we look at conservation
agriculture we see that those erosion
rates are much much
lower at 0.082 millimeters a year
and you know the conservation is taking
in these more sustainable practices
and then these are both um quite drastic
numbers when we look
against the average soil formation rates
in the on the planet
which are 0.017 millimeters a year so
basically we're building
soil up much more slowly than we're
eroding it
even under healthy systems
so part of these grasslands the uh
eastern most part of these grasslands is
the tall grass prairie
and this map that you see here on the
screen in light green
this is the original extent of the
tallgrass prairie
and in dark green we see what is
left as remnants or undisturbed prairie
so this is a nature conservancy map from
2010
i will tell you that we've lost a lot of
these prairies since then
and i want to stop for a moment and
define what a remnant prairie
is so for our purposes and the purposes
of my research
a remnant prairie soil is a soil that
has not been cultivated
or tilled by modern agriculture so i
mean
since the advent of modern agriculture
it hasn't been farmed
it's important to note that it has been
managed
most of these remnants are managed by
people like the nature conservancy or
nebraska's game and parks organization
and they do prescribe burning they do
some tree removal
specifically cedars and
they also do some grazing and this is
really
actually essential to preserve the
prairies because otherwise you're going
to have tree
encroachment um like you can see in this
picture
i have included here on the screen this
is us driving up to one of the remnant
prairies
and you can see the trees really do want
to to creep into that ecosystem
all right so this kind of brings me to
our research objectives
so we were really interested in
evaluating and quantifying the soil
health of these remnant tall grass
prairies in nebraska
using a suite of physical biological and
chemical
soil health analysis tests
we're also interested in comparing these
data
with active agricultural sites that were
directly json or in very close proximity
to these remnant prairies
and then finally we were interested in
comparing both
of those results with um the cornell
soil health
database on prairie state soils
so um we were and we were
i'm gonna discuss how we were able to do
that all right
so i want to stop and talk for a second
about benchmark or comparison or
goal oriented sampling we say often in
the lab when you're approaching sampling
and sampling strategies should really
have
a good question so because you can learn
so much more from comparing two samples
to each other then you can from one
sample
just kind of floating out there in space
right
so i'll point out this sort of little
map
in the beginning which lays out the
sampling strategy
and in this case we would be looking at
no-till versus
plow till and we would go out and we
would sample
in a w shaped pattern across our area of
interest
and we would be avoiding any spots that
looked like they had like really
vigorous growth
and we'd also be avoiding any spots that
looked like it had really poor growth
so basically we're looking for a
representation
of what's actually out in the field
and our study sites were along the
eastern side of nebraska and i put some
stars here that you can see the
approximate locations
of these sites and we were able to
identify
five remnant prairie sites we found
these through nebraska
game and parks commission as well as
through some
literature review and some scientists
who had done research
on these tall grass prairie microbial
communities specifically
um and then we were able to identify
active agricultural
sites that were either adjacent or in
very close proximity as i mentioned
now all of these accidents had a corn
soy rotation
none of them were using cover crops
um and we also determined that all of
the sites had a similar soil type they
had a similar slope they had a
similar geographic location
they're all less derived molosols
and um you know we kind of made those
decisions before we even went out there
to be sure that these really would be
valid comparisons
all right so then at each site we went
out and we collected five samples
um in the method that i had mentioned a
few slides
prior and those samples were taken about
25 meters apart
which is the way that's been
standardized by the cornell soil health
lab
and we took a single 0 to 30 centimeter
sample and you can see here on this
picture
that's exactly what they look like we
kind of did the slice of bread technique
again from the cornell soil health lab
and then we manually measured and
divided it
into a 0 to 15 centimeter sample and a
15 to 30
centimeter sample so each location
resulted
in 10 soil samples and then total we
ended up with 90 soil samples
all right so here feels like a good
place to introduce the lab
so of course i am the manager of the
cornell soil
health lab i've been working with the
lab for almost
10 years in a couple months here it'll
be 10 years
um so it was really an obvious choice
for a comprehensive way to look at these
soils
so the lab opened in 2007
it was the first commercially available
soil health test
we've analyzed well over 10 000 samples
from around the world we hold to my
knowledge
the world's largest global soil health
database
excuse me and we're currently working on
regional soil health databases so by
that i mean
we're starting to separate it into
different areas
and look at soil health for nebraska for
instance
um which is very exciting
okay so within the lab we have the
comprehensive
assessment of soil health the cash test
which is basically what we used um to
analyze these soils
and i'm going to briefly just go through
uh
what we looked at and sort of what it
means i'm not going to talk about our
laboratory
processes although i easily could if you
guys have questions about it
all right so we looked at the biological
we looked at quite a suite of biological
factors including organic matter
which is quite simply carbon containing
material
derived from living organisms and we
looked at the percentage
of this organic matter we also looked at
soil protein which is a way to get at
the organically bound
nitrogen in the soil organic matter
we looked at soil respiration which is a
measure of the metabolic
activity of the soil microbial community
we looked at active carbon which is
basically up the portion of organic
matter that's easily available for the
microbial
community as a food and energy source
we looked at total carbon which includes
organic carbon
and inorganic carbon and we looked at
total nitrogen which is the same idea
looking at organic and inorganic
nitrogen
we also looked at a few
physical parameters texture which is
quite simply the percentage of sand silt
and clay
and aggregate stability so aggregates
are basically
those little crumbs of soil you can kind
of see in this picture here in the
middle
and they're held together by the hyphae
and by that microbial community that
really helps to make them more stable
and the way that we look at it is what
percentage
are stable under a rain simulation
and then of course we also looked at ph
the major nutrients
and the minor nutrients
all right so if you were to submit a
sample to our lab you would receive a
report from us the front page of which
is all the way on the left hand side of
the screen
and i just want to point out that this
is divided into physical
and purple green biological and
chemicals
aspects of your soil and then i'll draw
your attention to the rating kind of in
the middle of the report there
and you can see that we use a color
coded reading system
so basically what this is is dark green
means you're in the top
20 of everything we've received in the
lab
very much on the high end the red is
that you're in the
bottom 20 so you've got some major
issues going on and then you can see
how the rainbow kind of works in between
and this is really all based off of
or interpreted using the textural
triangle which i've put here on the
screen as well
so your soil texture is going to have a
lot to do
with the potential of your soil so
if you look here on our scoring function
graph
in the solid line you can see the coarse
textured soil that would be a sand
the um dot and dash line in the middle
that's a medium textured soil that's a
silt
loam something like that which is what
our samples were and what i'm going to
be talking about today
and then the dashed lines are the fine
textured soil which is a clay
soil
all right so now i want to move big
picture into some results
this is composited data for all of our
sites
and what i did is i took um this
the scoring curve and the colors and i
actually superimposed them over
onto the box plots because i wanted to
really easily visually show
where our samples were falling in
against
the average of what we received in the
lab
so in the light blue that are that is
the ag samples
the dark blue is the remnant prairie
soils
and you can see that the organic matter
in this case in the ag soils is actually
not that bad
it's in the light green kind of
up there towards four percent a little
over at some points but then when we
look at the remnant prairie
we see it's well up into the dark green
stretching all the way up above seven
percent
in one or two cases so this is um
right off the bat a pretty good takeaway
as to the differences among these soils
moving in to active carbon this is
another
biological result we saw the most
pronounced differences in the biological
results
um we can see the active carbon here so
again this is kind of that
quality of organic matter um that
food source for the microbes and we see
that in the ag
it's in the light green and stretching
into the yellow so kind of
average-ish whereas when we look at the
remnant prairie we see
it's almost like topping it out so if
you look at our chart you know it kind
of
tops out at 1200 it's all super dark
green over there at the 900 parts per
million
so we have very high active carbon in
these remnant prairies
we saw a very similar um
pattern in the respiration whereas
which is the uh an indicator of
the functioning of that microbial
community the activity of the
microbial community and this is a lot
more dramatic
in that we see the ag is down there in
the orange and yellow so
orange typically in our lab if someone
had orange
or red results i would say you've got
pretty serious issues that you need to
start paying attention to
so we're starting to really see some of
this degradation
in the ag soil when we're looking at
this respiration
and then of course looking at the
prairie again it's full on dark green
it's really looking quite good um
and high so i had mentioned
that we um have paired samples
so i wanted to just take one slide to
give you
all an idea of what this looks like so
what i did
is with these kind of checked lines here
i divided
um the different paired samples so i
think you'll see
one egg one p those samples went
together
two ag two p those ones went together so
forth
all the way on the right hand side of
that box plot you'll see that we
actually have one ag site and two
remnant prairies
kind of confusing but it was like you
know if you get offered another remnant
prairie you're just gonna sample it
while you're there
you know it just makes sense and then of
course i also again superimpose the
color coding system
because these aggregate stability
results are really
in my opinion quite extreme so i want to
point
out um that first one ag in one p
i was looking back through my notes last
night and according to the farmer
that i talked to they started farming in
1967
so remnant prairie so this is the amount
of difference that we can assume has
happened since
1967 as we learned from earlier slides
most of the american prairie was broken
way way way before that
so we can see that probably in the case
of the
four ag for instance you know that
there's been a lot more time
for this soil to really degrade
all right so then we also did some kind
of like really big picture stats
we looked at the pearson's correlation
coefficient
one of the big takeaways from this is
that the organic matter and the organic
matter
quality indicators show the highest
correlation
so i went ahead on my color coding
track and i highlighted everything that
was above
0.70 as being a very strong positive
relationship
as well as everything in the point 40 to
0.69
um with the lighter green just to give
you guys kind of visually
a quick uh look at what these um
relationships really look like
so we can see a very strong correlations
between
carbon content and that microbial
community
we also see increases with the organic
matter
conducive to accumulations of available
potassium
and the total and available nitrogen um
this all makes sense we also see a
little bit with
of correlations and strong relationships
with the magnesium
again these are associated kind of with
your quality of organic matter
so to me this whole pattern is really
driven
by that organic matter in the system and
this is
looking at the ag sites and the prairie
sites together
so we are also interested of course in
understanding if there are differences
existing
[Music]
among the sites so we can see
that the first component here drove
about 33
of the variation and this was mostly on
biological
drivers like the active carbon aggregate
stability
carbon things along those lines and then
it looks like that second component is
really driving that separation of the ag
we think that this has a lot to do with
ph
the remnant prairies on average had a ph
of 6.83
versus the active ag had a average ph
more like six so that's actually quite a
difference
and it's unsurprising that that would be
a driver
of these principal um component
differences here
all right so um kind of the third
goal was about creating a target
right and a big part of that was about
comparing our results to the results
that we've gotten from the lab
so again i've gone in here and i've
color coded this
according to the ratings that we would
give
in the lab so all the way to the left we
have the prairie state
silt loams i wanted to only compare my
results against
other silt loam samples so this is
compared against
samples and then in the middle we have
our agricultural sites
and then all the way to the right we
have our prairie sites
so i think that this does a few
different things one it shows the high
quality of our remnant
prairie sites they are indeed higher on
all parameters than any of the other
sites that we've looked at
there is this glaring red in the prairie
sites that we've gotten from the
lab and that's in phosphorus it's really
high levels of phosphorus this is
probably
due to adding manure to a lot of these
agricultural
fields and then we do even see higher
levels of phosphorus on our agricultural
sites here in the middle but what i
think is really important about this
is we established targets right so a lot
of like the ecological restoration
papers talk about how we have to have
targets to aim towards but they don't
really
exist in any kind of like realistic
scale so the whole idea is that we used
this lab that's really accepted for
research it's well established and we're
using that to set up these parameters
for these goals which i think we are
able to do
all right so some key takeaway concepts
so our ag sites that we looked at in
nebraska
all had really high yields i looked up
the average yields for that year it was
actually a drought year
and i only got reported back half of the
yields but they were
way higher than what was on average for
that year so that's a big deal
because we still saw really some
significant degradation in these
agricultural systems
we are also able to establish
this benchmark data for that targeted
restoration efforts like i showed on
this
previous slide we saw 41
lower total carbon in the ag sites when
prepared
when um compared to the remnant prairies
that's a really really big difference
and we're talking about these grasslands
being these huge carbon sinks everyone's
super interested in carbon right now
this is really showing us that those
agricultural systems
are breaking down that um carbon storage
and we are able to show that indeed
these remnants
are very high quality and an appropriate
goal
all right and then i just wanted to
touch a little bit on some like big
picture
applications of this data if i were to
continue working on this project i would
probably
approach the farmers that we worked with
and asked them if we could put in strip
trials
if we could try to target some of these
specific soil health properties we know
how to improve soil health it doesn't
happen quickly
but there's methods for doing it
specific cover crops various things
and i would go in and see if we could
indeed jump start
and improve these agricultural systems i
believe that this work could
serve as a model for expanding into
other grassland ecosystems
across the world and across the united
states
this information could be applied
towards the remediation
of desertified grasslands so for
instance in ningxa
china where rebecca works really closely
these um desertified grasslands used to
be
just like this big this tall grass
prairie soils
that's what they were but they've been
doing agriculture for way way longer
than we have been
in the united states and you know
they've really pushed it
way past just a little bit of degraded
aglan to where it's actually turning
into desert
that they're actively working on
bringing back and
finally i think it's really important to
share
to collaborate so i believe that this
information should be provided to other
big soil databases and global soil
databases in order to
to help improve in general uh
all of our work basically
all right with that um i have to say
thank you
so much to my committee especially um my
chair rebecca schneider who worked with
me
um very closely on all of this work as
well
as harold van s my boss
and colleague and co-committee chair and
steven moriel also from natural
resources we do have an additional
co-author from china
our work was funded by the ningxia
forest institute in china
as well as some of the sample analysis
were funded
in part by usda nrcs conservation
innovation grants so i'm
super thankful for that funding and
i also have listed just some of the
people that
this work couldn't have been possible
without in one way or another sometimes
it was just through
converse inspiring conversations
sometimes
it was from like sitting down and really
digging through the data
so yeah thank you all so much for your
attention
and for the opportunity to pursue this
education
at cornell i really appreciate it
great great you want to um stop sharing
screen
and we'll see if anybody has a question
they want to ask
and i'm going to get my chair i have to
stand sitting
talk standing up but i think i can
answer questions sitting down
great great
anybody have any questions we're
obviously going to be asking our
questions in a few minutes but um in
case you all had
yeah anything got a quick question here
liz ricky uh
so yeah very nice presentation first of
all um
but yeah so you mentioned using these
soils as benchmarks for the midwest
would you what would you say would be an
appropriate benchmark for somewhere else
in the country maybe the northeast
would you say yeah that's a great
question
i think so there's actually remnant
sites you can find in lots of different
systems
like even in new york city there's um
you know these really old cemeteries
it sounds really weird right but there's
these really really old cemeteries like
from like revolutionary war
times that have these same ideas
of these remnant you know never
disturbed never
touched microbial communities things
like that and there's other scientists
who have used cemeteries
i've heard some funny stories about
people getting in trouble for going and
taking samples in cemeteries but i think
that you could
you know like maybe in new york it would
probably be
pretty tricky but i do think it would be
possible
maybe even in like long-term um
like fence lines things like that like
places that you just know like borders
right that like no one has really messed
with then you can go in you can look at
that
against you know what has been
manipulated but i do think that
yeah the concept of remnants and the
concept of like
goals you know benchmarks is gonna be a
valuable way of assessing
um soil health moving forward based on
based on my reading and my work
thanks
okay well uh it doesn't look like
there's any other questions
thank you all for coming um and we
appreciate it
rebecca i'm sorry i didn't get off the
mute fast enough i did have
oh sure go erin no problem uh great job
kirsten it was good to see you and good
to see everyone else thank you
um so you know i work a lot with
extension so mine's an
extension related question but i was
wondering given the information that you
have you have the soil health
tests um and the other information that
you presented
how would you go about convincing a
farmer
to implement these practices you know
what what would be something that you
would try to do to convince them that
this was good
something good for them on their farm
and would benefit them
as well as the the wrestler that's a
great question also
i think that one of those last slides
that was all cover
color coded where i showed like our
database i think the database and this
work that's being done by like harold
and joseph vancili on moving into this
regional
zone right because it's like it's not
really fair to say
you want to have a target that's
realistic for them
right so you're saying like okay this is
like kind of the best
possible thing for your area and we know
this is possible
right so this is a target so instead of
saying like oh let's just in general try
to build your soil health
instead we could say all right we're
going to try to build up your active
carbon
by this specific amount you're heading
towards this goal
which like as you know as everyone in
this audience knows it takes
years to build up soil health so this
goal could take them
five or ten years but when you start to
think about like
land valuation for their you know the
people who are going to inherit this
property their children
things like that i think that you can
really sell the idea
of like how important it is to at least
be
aiming there you know but it's through
this target it's through having these
like realistic specific
regional goals i think that's what
because to me i mean you look at that
and also like
simplifying it the way that you
communicate right like this idea of like
color
coding it so you just look at it and
you're like oh my gosh that's like
totally dark green and i'm only light
green
like i can do that you know it's like a
positive encouragement kind of a thing
that's how i would do it all right thank
you
thank you all right guys
thank you all for coming we'll wait for
you all to leave i'm putting uh paul's
when i record
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu